thank you I just had to wear the
Stanford red this morning can you hear
me is this on yeah okay I do want to
take your question so I'll try not to
talk for more than 25 or 30 minutes so
we'll have plenty of time
I was asked how long it took me to write
the book that I've just released tough
choices and I answered that it took me
almost as long to decide to write it as
it did to write it took me about six
months to think very long and hard about
whether I wanted to write this book I
knew that if I wrote a book I would want
to write it myself which I did every
word there's no ghostwriter there's no
collaborator for better or for worse it
is my words about my feelings my
experiences I knew that I would want to
write an authentic book what I mean by
authentic is a straightforward book a
book that tells it like it has been in
my life and my career and that was a
tough choice in a way because when you
decide to be authentic you have to be
authentic about yourself so while I had
been a very public figure I had also
been a very private person and this is a
book that reveals much about me
personally in my life I also concluded
that I would be authentic about the
experiences that I've had and not all
those experiences have been good and of
course that creates controversy as well
but I wanted to write this book for
about five years now and the first
inspiration to write this book came
actually when I was sitting on a witness
stand being cross-examined you may
remember a small somewhat controversial
merger with Compaq Computer and you may
remember that after a sort of massive
battle shareholder battle we finally won
the vote to consummate that deal
and there was one last hurdle to get
over which was we were sued one last
time we were sued because the claim was
that we had overestimated the amount of
cost synergies that we could get from
the merger we had said we would achieve
two and a half billion dollars in cost
synergies we went on to achieve three
and a half billion but at that time the
lawsuit was that that was not accurate
that we were overstating in order to win
a shareholder vote so we went to court
in Delaware and I sat on the witness
stand and I got asked questions for
about a day and a half and what occurred
to me sitting on that stand and
answering those questions is that most
people really don't have an idea about
how a company operates because all the
questions were about how do you set
goals how do you find common cause and
common language with people so that they
put their energies against those common
goals and so it occurred to me that one
day I would write a book about the story
of business and I think the story of
business is all about the story of
people now I got to business school
degrees and I know in business school we
talk about profits and particularly if
you're here in the valley you talk a lot
about products and you talk about how
you're going to get rich quick and all
of that stuff but the truth is that in
my experience it is people who produce
both products and profits and if you
don't understand people if you don't
have a sense of why people behave as
they do you can't change what they do
and if you cannot change what people are
doing you cannot change either products
or profits and so I decided to write a
book about business through people for
me actually the fun the fascination the
challenge the privilege of leading in a
business is all about working with
people as was mentioned I did not
imagine that I would be a business
executive I had a degree in medieval
history and philosophy from here at
Stanford at the history corner it was
really fascinating
but it wasn't gonna pay the bills I went
off to law school because that's what my
parents wanted me to do after about a
semester in law school I concluded I
hated it and I also concluded that
probably pleasing my parents was not a
good life goal sounds silly but that was
a revelation to me and that was probably
the first real adult choice I made and
for me that was a very tough choice I
dropped out of law school and I had to
pay the bills so I do did the only thing
I knew how that would pay the bills
immediately and that was I went off to
work as a secretary I typed and I
answered the phones and I worked at a
company called Marcus and millet chap
which is on Hanover Street one block
from the headquarters of Hewlett Packard
now when I took that job I didn't think
it was beneath me I thought it was a
good job because it paid my bills and I
threw myself into that job I wanted to
be a good secretary and receptionist
which has formed the basis of the career
advice I'd given ever since which is
whatever job you have learn everything
you can from that job I was in that job
about six months and two men who worked
there came up to me one day and said you
know we think maybe you could do more
would you like to help us write some
deals and that was my first introduction
to business that was the first time it
ever occurred to me that maybe I could
become a business person my family
didn't really have any exposure to
business my father was an academic he
taught at the law school for part of his
career here at Stanford my mother was a
full-time homemaker and an artist and
those two men taught me something really
important in fact they taught me one of
the most important lessons of leadership
and that is that leadership is all about
seeing the possibilities leadership is
all about seeing the possibilities in
people
seeing the possibilities in
circumstances those two gentlemen saw
possibilities in myself that I did not
know were there and because they could
see that I saw something different in
myself as well leadership is all about
the possibilities I think there is a
huge difference between leadership and
management management is about the
production of known and acceptable
results within known conditions and
constraints leadership is about changing
the order of things now when those two
men taught me my very first important
lesson about leadership that leadership
is about seeing the potential in others
leadership is about seeing the
possibilities in things that then caused
me to think differently about my own
future this book is also about fear I
talk a lot about fear in this book my
own fears but the fears also of people
that I have encountered along the way
and I don't talk about fear because it's
some psychobabble I talk about fear
because fear is a principal motivator in
business people fear change so if you
want people to change what they're doing
you have to understand what they're
afraid of the natural momentum of any
organization is to preserve the status
quo why is that well because people are
afraid of the unknown people are afraid
to try something new
but it's also because whatever
institution you're talking about whether
it's the Stanford Business School or its
Hewlett Packard or it was 80 when I
first entered it people who have
positions of power and influence want to
keep them the status quo advantages them
and so they seek to preserve their
advantage
that is human nature one of the things
that I didn't know when I started out as
a secretary is that people are people
wherever you find them
I actually thought when I was a
secretary talking with the guys in the
mailroom I thought that those people up
there you know the big bosses the big
executives they must be different
somehow those people who've made tons of
money in business they must be different
somehow the truth is they're not the
truth is people are people wherever you
go and that means that some people are
able to set their fears or their own
personal agendas aside and some are not
so understanding fear and understanding
how to motivate people effectively so
that they can move beyond their fear and
actually try something new is
fundamental to looting change if
leadership is about changing the order
of things then a leader has to
understand that resistance comes with
the territory resistance comes with the
territory because people in positions of
power want to keep them and because
everyone is afraid one of the things
that terrified me when I first started
in business is some of the circumstances
that I found my very first job at a TNT
after I was a secretary I ran off to
Italy and taught English for a while and
I was sort of searching that I got an
MBA finally I show up at 80 and 80 back
then was the Bell System there were a
million employees in the Bell System old
mob Bell I know most of you too young to
remember but it was a big huge
bureaucracy and I joined that company as
a brand new salesperson my very first
job was to share an account very
lucrative profitable account with a
older gentleman I say he was older I
think in retrospect he was about my age
but
I thought he was older and it came time
to meet the clients and he comes to me
and he says you know Carly I know that
we've planned to have you meet these
clients but I'm afraid you won't be able
to do that I said well why not he said
well because we're gonna be going to the
boardroom I said well what's the
wardroom well the boardroom was a strip
club it was a very famous strip club
where the women would dress in babydoll
negligees see-through babydoll negligees
and danced on top of the table while the
clients ate lunch I was terrified and I
had to think long and hard about well
what do i do do I show up at this
meeting I finally decided I had to again
most of you not all of you are too young
to remember this but there was a book
called how to dress for success for
women in the 80s a few of you remember
that and you know it recommended very
conservative suits and collars up to
little bow ties you know so I dressed
that way that day
and I carried my briefcase my newly
purchased briefcase like a shield of
honor and I get into the cab and I say
to the cab driver I'd like to go to the
boardroom and he turned around and said
are you new the new Act so I get there
and I come in you know it's this dark
place it's loud it's noisy there's this
long bar down the side there's a stage
right here and my colleagues have seated
themselves way over there and the only
way I can get there is to walk across
that stage with my briefcase and my bow
tie and of course wouldn't you know
they're 10 women having act you know
I really did look like an idiot and I
was terrified now two hours later
probably my male colleagues were even
more uncomfortable than I was and when
that day was over everything had changed
when I came back to the office
everything was different because I had
shown that while I was terrified I
wouldn't be intimidated and while I
could not pick those circumstances I
could choose how I dealt with them and
that gentleman colleague and I we never
talked about that again but we became
great colleagues great teammates we
found a way to find common ground and
that also is what business is all about
finding common ground and common
language so that you can approach common
goals my when I became a manager for the
first time I remember being introduced
to my new team of people I only managed
three people but to me it was a huge
accomplishment and I was introduced as
our token bimbo now why do I tell you
these stories I tell you these stories
because I believe everyone faces
situations that are difficult and
frightening everyone has to choose how
to deal with those but I also tell them
because business should be but business
is not yet a meritocracy I mentioned
that 80 was a huge organization and like
many large organizations most large
organizations at the end of every year
employees would be evaluated they would
be given performance ratings and
rankings and the way that occurred at
AT&T is the same way it occurred in
hewlett-packard or any other large
company as groups of managers would come
together and they would talk about their
employees and I imagined initially that
this was a very rational process you
know everybody would come in they would
have all their employees accomplish
they would talk about it in a reasoned
way and of course bosses would be
willing to say well yeah it sounds like
your employee did more than mine of
course they should be rated higher well
I found out very quickly in that first
session that isn't how a lot of people
operate some people do but for some
people that rating and ranking session
was all about a power struggle it was
all about I'm a better boss if I have
more employees who are rated higher I
also found out that day why a
meritocracy is so difficult to build
it's difficult to build because people
are comfortable with people like
themselves that's human nature it's not
bad it's not good it's just human nature
and so I observed that when people were
talking about their employees if the
employee was a lot like the boss the
boss was more comfortable with them they
knew them better and therefore they
would talk more fluently and more
enthusiastically about that employee's
accomplishments and if the employee was
different than the boss the boss was a
little uncomfortable with the employee
then the boss talked with less fluency
and less enthusiasm that is why
meritocracies are difficult to build
because people are more comfortable in
many cases with people like them
business of course should be a
meritocracy it is much better when
everybody can play which is why from the
in 1998 when Fortune magazine named me
the most powerful woman in business for
the first year by the way think about it
that first year Oprah Winfrey was number
two I mean that's ridiculous on its face
but it made a great story and from 1998
on for each of the next six years that I
was named the most powerful woman in
business I would say to fortune don't do
a numbered list if you want to highlight
women who are successful in business
great but when you number us one to 50
you imply that business is like
Hennis there's the women's ladder and
there's the men's ladder and women have
to compete against each other one two
fifty because we're not strong enough or
good enough to compete against the guys
business ought to be a sport where
everybody gets to play and when
everybody can play the game is better
and we have still a ways to go
I believe that change requires both
optimism and realism realism cold-eyed
clear-eyed realism about where things
really are I also believe it requires
optimism because optimism is the belief
that things can get better and unless
you're an optimist you can't change
anything pessimism and cynicism are easy
you don't have to do anything all you
have to do is kind of comment and
critique so back to the subject of
change and needing cold-eyed realism
when I came to hewlett-packard in 1999
this was an iconic company a mythic
company with founders that were
larger-than-life and hewlett-packard had
deep emotional significance for people
and as the years went by history became
mythology and mythology almost became
religion and yet this was also a company
in 1999 that was falling further and
further behind in the middle of the
biggest technology upturn in history
this company had missed nine quarters in
a row while the company was lagging
behind in every market in which it
competed missing nine quarters in a row
in the middle of the biggest technology
upturn in history employees were getting
record bonuses why because the way
success was measured inside the business
had nothing to do with the way success
was measured in the marketplace we were
no longer a meritocracy 82% of our
employees had said for each of the past
10 years that the company didn't deal
with poor performance
75% of our people were superior or
excellent what used to be a meritocracy
became a bureaucracy we were a
technology company and yet we no longer
innovated we were no longer even in the
top 25 innovators in the world we had
this set of values called the HP way but
people had stopped talking about the
values themselves and what they really
meant and started instead just using the
shorthand the caricature the label the
HP way and the problem was that the HP
way became a way of stopping change
innovation I would go to meetings and
people which I would observe people
would say well we don't do it that way
it's not the HP way when culture becomes
convention then something has to change
I said that I think business is all
about people there are probably people
some among you I've worked around
technologists all my life I am NOT a
technologist by training but I've worked
around engineers managed engineers
worked with technology companies all my
career and I know that for many
technologists talk about people and
behavior and values and culture it just
sounds like a bunch of BS it's soft
stuff the truth is I think culture and
values and behavior the stuff that makes
people tick is actually the really hard
stuff a better analogy I think is it is
software it is the software of a company
and just like in a computer system if
you want to change a company if you want
a computer to perform more effectively
you have to deal with the software as
well as the hardware for hewlett-packard
the hardware was what is our strategy we
had to choose to lead once again we had
to choose to say you know what we want
to be
a leading company in the 21st century we
had to change how we structured our
business fundamentally we were 87
standalone business units none of them
talked or coordinated among one another
for customers believe it or not when I
arrived at HP we didn't even know how
many employees we had because 87
different business units all had their
own everything their own IT systems
their own HR systems their own brands
and the heads of those businesses
jealously guarded that power it is human
nature so we had to change how we were
organized so we could collaborate more
effectively on behalf of customers we
had to put together processes so that
for example at the end of my tenure we
had a single email system not 87 pretty
important if people are going to
communicate effectively we had to change
how we measured and rewarded performance
and when you start changing how people
are paid it is deeply personal when you
start to say to people you know what
it's not actually realistic or
competitive to have 75 percent of our
people be rated superior or excellent
when we are failing to compete in the
marketplace logically people understand
it but emotionally it is very personal
for people when you have to take you
know during my tenure I took 36,000
people off the payroll that's very hard
people become angry resentful and then
there's all this really important
software called culture and values and
so we had to go back to things like you
know what innovation is one of the most
important values in the HP way what does
innovation mean well it means we
actually have to innovate it means we
have to invest in innovation it means we
have to measure and value and reward
innovation I asked when I first arrived
how many patents do we produce nobody
knew
I asked what percentage of our revenue
stream comes from new product
introductions nobody knew
by the time I left we were generating 11
patents a day for two years in a row and
we had become once again among the top 5
innovators in the world that kind of
change fundamental transformation from
the bottom up not to mention a huge
controversial merger undertaken in a
bear market announced the week before
September 11th in a down economy in a
technology recession that kind of
transformation not only creates huge
resistance but it also takes a
tremendous amount of time so this book
is a lot about change and what it really
takes and what's the software of change
as well as the hardware of change now of
course as was mentioned in then in the
introduction you sort of can't talk
about the story of me or the story of
Hewlett Packard without also saying
something about the media and I'd be
happy to talk more about this when I
take your questions which I'm gonna do
in about one minute here but I think as
business people it's important for you
to think about what is the impact when
in this always-on Information Age fact
fiction and fantasy are out there and
they have equal Authority think about
the information flow you get every day
fact fiction fantasy opinion informed or
not have equal weight it's hard to
distinguish between them it is a part of
what is going on around us and so how
does a leader both be aware of that but
also stay focused on the mission at hand
and keep people focused on the mission
at hand
this book is also about something that I
don't think we talked enough about as
businesspeople and that is the
fundamentals of judgment perspective and
ethics I'm troubled as a business person
that every time we see some new scandal
or some dysfunction in a boardroom in an
executive suite I'm troubled that when
we see all of this backdating of stock
options for example people kind of
immediately run to what rules should we
change when Tyco and Enron and world
come and in Delphia happened everybody
started thinking about how do we change
the rules and some of those changes and
rules are helpful but when you think
about backdating of stock options that
it appears to me that what has happened
among other things is people have said
if there's not a rule that says I can't
I can there is no substitute for
judgment there is no substitute for
personal ethics there is no substitute
for a sense of values that say you know
what there is a difference between
what's right and what's wrong and it
matters but if you believe that as a
leader the tone has to be set at the top
because people watch the walk rather
than listen to the talk and so not only
does a role a leader have to role model
that but it means sometimes the toughest
choices you have to make are to fire
somebody not because they're not getting
results but because their values and
their judgment are inconsistent with
what you say you stand for the toughest
personnel choices I've ever had to make
in my career or where I've had to deal
with people who are abusive or dishonest
and let's be honest with one another
abusive dishonest people get results in
business
if you tolerate it if you send a message
that that's okay
then everybody concludes that's okay all
that matters are do you get the numbers
if you want people to actually believe
that values matter and character counts
then you have to act even if people are
getting results based on their behavior
I was taught long ago and I'm gonna stop
here and take your questions I was
taught long ago that values are what
guide your behavior when no one's
looking and when you think no one will
find out and if you don't have a strong
set of values it will infect the
organization of which you are a part and
we see many many examples of that every
day all around us
unfortunately finally how many of you
have read any part of Bob Woodward's
trilogy about the Iraq war I happen to
be reading right now state of denial any
of you read any of that stuff
not so wow you must be studying really
hard well set aside your politics for a
moment among other things what those
books are about is how a political
process can become dysfunctional because
people's personal agendas personal
rivalries personal fears get in the way
of a sound decision-making process
it happens in business every day it
happens in boardrooms it happens in mail
rooms it happens in every management
meeting and so a big part of what has to
happen in any team of people is to pay a
lot of attention to the decision-making
process and whether people are putting
the real issues up on top of the table
and talking about them and debating them
and understanding them fully or are they
hiding the real issues under the table
if you have people who are hiding issues
under the table
and are not able to put all the facts
all the opinions up on the table before
a decision is made you won't get a sound
business decision and yet it happens all
the time these are the software of
business and there are things that good
leaders have to understand or you cannot
change anything because change is all
about how people behave what they
believe and if you want to change
products and profits you have to change
those things about people okay I'm gonna
stop who wants to ask a question I think
their microphones we're supposed to wait
I think for microphones no you just
stand up and yes ma'am
well I think some of it is frankly we
just needed more practice you know old
habits are hard to break new habits of
honey and because we don't have enough
practice at some of this the language we
use and the experiences that occur are
just different I'll give you a recent
example I'll give you two weeks of
examples I shared a podium with Bill
Clinton recently and he said you know
when I talk about a topic and I'm
detailed about the topic people call me
something to me they call me erudite
when Hillary talks about the same topic
at the same length people say she's
lecture it's just an example of the
difference in language last week there
was a column that noted that both
Patricia Dunn the former chairman of
hewlett-packard and I were women and a
middle-aged white man decided to go on
and on about the sisterhood interesting
I learned a long time ago it's kind of
good to know what you don't know but but
beyond that what I found fascinating
about that was that very same week four
male CEOs bit the dust over stock option
backdating there was no comment about
the Brotherhood there was no comment
about the pattern when the CEOs of world
comm or Adelphia or Tyco or Enron all
stood up and declared their innocence
right until the end nobody talked about
victimhood
or Brotherhood the language is just
different so some of it is we just gotta
get more practice secondly as I said at
the outset I think people have got to
talk straight talk about real issues one
of the things I finally concluded in
hewlett-packard we talked a lot about
diversity we talked a lot about
meritocracy but we weren't making enough
progress and so I said in my tenure you
know what we're gonna measure it because
we measure everything else that's
important in this business that
diversity is important we're going to
measure it and we're going to expect
progress every single year and I think
finally so you got to talk about it you
have to make it part of what people
focus their attention on and business
runs by measurements results so if you
want to value something you have to
measure it finally I think that
businesses need to be a lot more
creative because we can be now with all
the tools of technology there are a lot
more creative about having an
environment where people can make their
own choices with the technology we have
at our disposal today and the 24-hour
nature of a global business there's no
reason that people have got to make
these agonizing choices between should I
be at the baseball game with my son or
daughter or should I be in the
conference room we ought to be able to
accommodate those kinds of things so all
those things matter yes sir
and then I'll start
so this week class tonight are launching
a series on women innovators and leaders
good salesmen well there you know
several right here in the valley I mean
Meg Whitman is a great women later
I'm delighted by the way that since I
left you at Packard there have been
three new women CEOs named and Indra Nui
for example of PepsiCo is an outstanding
leader and I think that the more
progress we can make in terms of talking
about leaders and showcasing leaders of
all kinds of all genders of all
backgrounds as opposed to saying let's
talk about women leaders the more
progress we're going to make because
there are some aspects of leadership
that have nothing to do with gender you
know a leader is an authentic
communicator that has nothing to do with
gender a leader tells it like it is that
has nothing to do with gender a leader
collaborates effectively with lots of
different people that has nothing to do
with gender so I would encourage you as
well to think about maybe instead of
perpetuating the latter thing you know
there are women leaders and men leaders
we ought to have a you ought to think
about a course in leadership and just
work really hard to make sure that
you're showcasing a very diverse group
of leaders which of course would include
women there was a yes sir
[Music]
well I do talk about that in the book
and it's also a great it's a great
opportunity to illustrate what I meant
before about the media so one of the
stories that came up a lot during my
tenure in addition the fact that I
travel with a hairdresser and a makeup
artist that's not true by the way and
you know we will have arrived when
people suggest that Donald Trump
maybe travels with her his hair is
really much more complicated than mine
but another another story that went
around all the time was well Carly was
too ambitious and so she chose not to
have children that became the story and
frankly a lot of women were angry about
that so one of the things I talk about
in this book is first of all I am
married my husband is standing right
back there that's Frank and the yellow
shirt
[Applause]
when we were married he had two young
daughters which we raised we now have
two granddaughters ten and two they're
perfect by the way we very much wanted
to have children worked hard to have
children of our own was not God's choice
so you can imagine how personally
hurtful it was for people to say well
she made this choice because she's such
an ambitious you know the B word every
successful person I don't care what your
definition of success is my definition
of success is have you made a positive
difference and do you own your soul at
the end of your journey because there
are lots of opportunities to give it up
and however you define success every
successful person has a family and
supporters around them I happen to have
had a great husband and a great gift and
when I became the CEO of Hewlett Packard
he retired from his own pretty
high-powered career to support me I
think that was a tremendous gift and a
tremendous choice
not all men understand that choice but
the point is it's our choice to make and
the work environment should be one in
which people can make their own choices
and whatever choice they make they also
can make a contribution
the experiences that really took
culminated and well that really is what
the book is about you know there are I
mean honestly they're they're you know
having written 360 pages I can't get it
down to one sentence but to try and be
responsive to your question I think I'll
give you an unexpected answer perhaps
every every job I had I learned
something from something important and I
think the goal is to bring all of your
experience and all of yourself to a
challenge however when I was growing up
we moved around a lot I went to five
high schools in four years I went to
school overseas I went to school in
various parts of the United States I
became used to accustomed to comfortable
with the pattern of change it became a
habit for me to feel afraid of going
into a new situation and then realizing
that if I could connect with people find
common language and common cause that I
could get over the fear and move on I
became used to that and so for me change
was not as frightening as it was for
other people was part of life that
helped me tremendously but I also knew
that feeling I recognized that feeling
that people have when they're so afraid
of what they're gonna have to let go
that they can't move forward and I
understand the resentment that change
can create as well
yes what is your take on the scandal too
late and that you had been thinking
about well I did have a week when I was
at hewlett-packard and first let me let
me say when you go through a
transformation of a company from bottom
to top culminating in a merger the
largest most complex merger ever
attempted in the history of the industry
and it still is that and you do that in
a bear market and a down economy in a
technology recession it's going to be
tough for a while and people are going
to take very much a wait-and-see
attitude and I bring all that up because
all of that creates pressure on board so
in January of 2005 when we when I faced
a leak the board felt tremendous
pressure the stock price was stuck the
press was bad despite the fact that we
had gone from a GAAP loss of 900 million
dollars in 2002 to a GAAP profit of 3
and a half billion in 2004 generating 11
pounds a day we were leading in every
business line every business was
profitable despite a clear trajectory of
progress press and stock price create
pressure the board and I were having a
discussion about how to reorganize it
the business and who to put in which
chair and we hadn't come to agreement on
that we agreed on some things and we
done them and we didn't agree on some
other things and so we had agreed to
continue talking that's what a
deliberate decision making process is
all about and about four days later I
see all of this on the front page of The
Wall Street Journal obviously that can
be very disruptive not to say against
the rules I mean that is a selective
disclosure that is material to a company
and a couple board members took it upon
themselves to put even more
Sharan the situation by putting
something in the wall street journal'
what I did was to talk plain we can't do
this we can't have a board room in which
confidentiality is not respected I had a
series of direct conversations with
board members who did this why did you
do this because again I know from 25
years in business that when people stop
talking directly and start going under
the table you know people can't speak
plainly with someone to their face they
go off and talk behind their back bad
things are gonna happen and then I asked
our outside counsel Larry since II need
to continue those direct conversations
no investigation no pretexting just
let's have some direct conversations but
my goal was to also have begin an
assessment process in my management
teams
I used 360-degree feedback I use tools
to help us assess the dynamics of our
decision-making processes because those
are things effective teams do and I and
a couple other board members had wanted
to bring those tools into the boardroom
it was resisted mightily some board
members thought it was a waste of time
why